he starts to back up and then
and they're telling him to stop they're
telling him to stop and then he tries to
drive over
some of the cops and they shoot at him
that's the video
even the unmasking of a story as untrue
doesn't actually change the story that
is told by the media
on racial issues the left's radicalism
is is being unmasked
pretty routinely this is pretty
astonishing today
mayor lori lightfoot the mayor of
chicago apparently
she has now announced she will only be
giving interviews to black and brown
reporters
this is just racist i mean i'm sorry
it's just racist if joe biden were to
say i'm only giving interviews
to white catholics everybody would say
that is
racist and that is discrimination lori
lightfoot says i will only give
interviews to people who look like me
and the entire left just kind of shrugs
that's the way that it goes
first of all it may violate
constitutional provisions she is a
government officer discriminating openly
on the basis of race
nbc 5 chicago political reporter mary
ann ahern took to twitter on tuesday's
state quote as chicago mayor reaches her
two-year midway point as mayor her
spokeswoman says lightfoot is granting
one-on-one interviews
only to black or brown journalists
apparently the same message was given
to wttw chicago tonight anchor and
correspondent parachutes who tweeted
i was told the same thing chicago
politics reporter heather sharon also
tweeted
i can confirm okay that is
probably a violation of the law but the
fact that this is even considered a
possible political strategy demonstrates
how insane
the left has become lori lightfoot is
considered a mainstream democrat
and yet this sort of thing is tolerated
not only tolerated but celebrated
on the left meanwhile false narratives
are trotted out on a regular basis and
then
when they fall apart you just never hear
about it again so here's a perfect
example
you may have heard because we talked
about it on the show about this case of
andrew brown jr right so andrew brown jr
was shot he's a 42 year old black man
and he was shot to death as he drove his
vehicle last month in elizabeth city
north carolina and you remember there
were there were big there was talk of
riots
there was a big protest that was held
the family did a big presser
and they had people like benjamin crump
there and there they accused the
officers in this case of pure murder
here is benjamin crump who can be found
at
every shooting of a black person by a
police officer justified or not he is
found there explaining that it is
actually just
dead straight murder here is benjamin
crump explaining that this was murder
and then it turns out
not too much attorney harry daniels
will put this in greater context
exactly all right execution
executions
okay so you can hear people shouting
that this is murder and that the cops
need to be arrested
and benjamin crump got up there and he
said the exact same thing well now it
turns out that the body cam footage has
been released
so yesterday they released the body cam
footage what happened here is that
andrew brown
was a drug dealer okay and they were
there to deliver a drug warrant it's all
a ledge right the ledge drug dealer they
were there to deliver a drug warrant
and andrew brown decided to try and run
down cops with his car so here is what
the body cam footage looked like
so you can see the cops they're hopping
out the guy's in his car he starts to
back up
and then and they're telling him to stop
they're telling him to stop
and then he tries to drive over some of
the cops and they shoot at him
right that's that's what happens okay so
when people say that he was unarmed a
car is a deadly weapon right if you run
over somebody with your car that is
considered assault with a deadly weapon
he andrew brown backs up once the
once the swat team arrives to deliver
the warrant and then
he proceeds to try and drive forward
through the cops
which is why the d.a came out and said
no there's not going to be a prosecution
pasco 10 county district attorney andrew
wumble said during a news conference
on tuesday that they were justified in
their actions the cops because they had
reason to believe they were in danger
andrew brown jr was fatally struck by
gunshots on april 21st according to the
washington post
as he attempted to drive away from
deputies who were executing a search
warrant on felony drug charges at his
home
womble who previously said the shooting
was justified held the news conference
to discuss details of the state's bureau
of investigation findings
womble said brown's attemptedly
escalated the situation from show of
force to an employment of force
during the news conference wamble
recounted the events of april 21st brown
was sitting in his dark bmw on the day
officers from multiple agencies
attempted to search to serve
search and arrest warrants based on
alleged drug activity at around 8 23 a.m
a detective drove his vehicle in front
of browns
to prevent any forward movement two
deputies approached brown's car on the
driver's side as two others moved toward
the passenger side with guns drawn as
they gave commands to brown
brown threw down his phone as officers
approached closer and quickly backed his
car away from officers as one had his
hand
on brown's driver door handle that
deputy was pulled over the hood of the
car
according to womble when brown backed up
enough to the point where he was blocked
by his home he turned his steering wheel
to the left toward the law enforcement
officers
who were scrambling to get out of the
way and yelling for him to stop
according to womble and the video
footage
the first shot was fired during this
moment piercing the front windshield of
brown's car as his vehicle continued
to move more shots followed hitting
brown's passenger window and rear
passenger side door while his vehicle
continued to accelerate
across a vacant lot toward a white van
occupied by an investigator officers
fire fired five additional
shots the total time as you can see from
the video is five seconds
okay so there are eyewitness statements
that suggested that it was much longer
that these officers basically were
waiting
and then they just shot him for no
reason at all but that is not
true okay it happens to be that in all
likelihood he was trying to conceal
evidence and then he was trying to run
over cops brown had abrasions on his
body that were caused by the shrapnel
apparently
and a plastic bag in his mouth with a
substance that's consistent with crystal
meth
although autopsy and toxicology reports
haven't been finalized according
to the d.a the footage shared by wumble
brought more questions by reporters at
the news conference who pressed him
about saying brown was aiming for
officers instead of fleeing
the clips have also prompted more
criticism about how authorities handled
sharing information
with the public and of course you have
people saying that the footage was
cherry-picked
okay um cherry pick that's the video
that's the video
and here's that we've now reached the
point in american life where even the
unmasking of a story is untrue
doesn't actually change the story that
is told by the media it just brings
further questions right when there's
video of jacob blake
holding a knife and resisting a rest and
reaching into his car
and there being a knife on the
floorboards of the car then we are told
that the cops still shouldn't have shot
him when there is full-on video
of a 16-year-old girl attempting to stab
to death another
16 year old girl while shouting that
she's going to kill her that is still
not enough for people remember that time
it was so cute when americans were naive
enough to believe that body cam footage
was actually going to answer a lot of
these questions
and then it turns out that people don't
give a damn about body cam footage
because the narrative is all that
matters
but here's the thing i think for most
americans the narrative is not all that
matters
when it comes to most americans they
believe what they see with their eyes
and the narratives that are being
promulgated by the media and by the
democratic party
are just they're just not true now there
are narratives promulgated by the right
that are not true
that happens too but as the masks come
off
the people in power are being unmasked
as people who are willing to twist fact
in order to achieve a political end and
you can see that in everything from
coveted policy
to race policy you can see it with
regard to what's going on currently
in the gaza strip with regard to israel
and hamas
the battle for the culture is heating up
we here at the daily wire are making
some big moves so be sure to like
subscribe
ring that bell because you're not going
to want to miss a single moment